У Берліні - бум цін на ринку нерухомості.
Цей сплеск можна порівняти з розігрітим ринком житла у Києві
періоду 2005-2008 років,
коли ціни росли майже щодня.
Це офіс агенції нерухомості,
яка орієнтується на вихідців з країн колишнього Радянського Союзу.
Директорка 10 років тому переїхала в Берлін з Харкова.
На мою думку, ринок справді перегрітий.
Однак це не заважає попиту з боку клієнтів,
у нас, як і раніше, безліч запитів.
Ринок перегрітий настільки,
що деякі будинки та квартири німецькі банки оцінюють
на 30 відсотків нижче ціни на ринку.
В Німеччині вже навіть фіксують скорочення інвестицій -
через ситуацію на ринку нерухомості.
Любов Баумґартнер пропонує поглянути на квартиру,
яку виставили на продаж.
Ми їдемо до району Кепенік на сході міста.
Люди пізно схаменулися.
Ми десять років тому вмовляли клієнтів.
Говорили, ось, дивіться, квартира за 15 тисяч, купуйте.
Берлін - столиця Німеччини! А клієнти крутили носом,
не хотіли купувати.
Зараз, звичайно, ті, хто тоді не купили, шкодують про це.
Попит як і раніше дуже високий.
У деяких клієнтів навіть панічний страх, що ціни ще більше зростуть.
Це змушує їх діяти тут і зараз.
Західний Берлін, район Шарлоттенбург,
хвилина ходьби від шопінг-бульвару Курфюрстендамм.
Практично у всіх берлінських агенціях з продажу нерухомості
працівники володіють російською мовою.
Менеджер з продажу Сона Фосс розповідає, що попит стабільний,
незважаючи на санкції та посилення валютного контролю.
Росіяни і російськомовні покупці
складають приблизно 20% клієнтів.
Наприклад, в цьому проекті російськомовні клієнти
вже купили десять квартир.
Причому один з вирішальних чинників - близькість до універмагу KaDeWe.
Близькість до KaDeWe? Ну, я не знаю...
ну мабуть співвідношення всього там,
можна шопінг зробити,
можна піти поїсти на шостому поверсі устриць -
наші люди люблять красиво жити.
Будівництво йде повним ходом, ціна квадратного метра -
від восьми тисяч євро. Попит стабільний,
клієнти себе не афішують.
Деякі купують квартири для своїх дітей-студентів.
Батьки - бізнесмени,
щоб діти не жили бідні в студентських гуртожитках,
ось, надають такі хороші батьки
люксус-апартмент для своєї дитини.
В районі Кепенік на сході міста все значно скромніше -
студію площею 36 квадратних метрів
разом з меблями пропонують за 120 тисяч євро.
Однак і це, за словами маклера,
нормальна ціна - покупець швидко знайдеться.